if you had to boil down your drag race
experience and just into just a couple
of words how would you sum it up I dream
come true
I stick tiara you my dear are the real
thing now sashay away I grown so much
from my time being here then you show me
how to be myself for that I thank you
what do you hope The fans walk away
thinking about you aside from life the
materialistic things like the makeup the
hair like the outfits I coming into this
show I want to represent some things
that growing up I didn't have and I want
to represent an Asian minority yeah
immigrants yeah and we're immigrated
here at a young age and who didn't know
any better and so I stay true to myself
and make my way to the top so I want I
want them to know that big themself is
okay as long as you believe in yourself
other will believe in you too what did
it mean to you to be a part of the most
diverse season of drag race yet I feel
very blessed and very grateful to Asians
in one in one season that that's a
record and to see my culture and my
ethnicity being represented I'm just so
lucky here we're moving into mainstream
and it's just gonna get bigger and
better did you walk away with any
friends for life out of this game for
sure for sure I made a connection with
every single girl and I honestly can say
that most of the girls like like I
talked to I talk to on a daily basis we
always be like hey girl how you doing
what you need it's not just like oh hey
how are you once in a while kind of
thing we really take care of each other
it's a special bond that we get to share
throughout this crazy whirlwind so I
think I really treasure her everything
that we can
[Music]